[Music]
welcome to openings explain Jonathan
trunks who I clearly AM NOT I am Dennis
Russo and for Jonathan all he recovers
from his amazing and comprehensive 10
part series on the semi sloth Botvinnik
variation obviously just kidding
Johnson's a little busy with a norms
tournament that we've got coming around
the corner so I happily filled in to go
over one of my favorite openings and you
would expect from the player of my
strength that this would be one of my
favorites because while I have somewhat
of an understanding of positional chest
I'm at heart a coffee-shop player and I
love gambit lines which disregards the
idea of maintaining material equality
from the beginning on end in exchange
for rapid attacking chances rapid
development and just overall fair to
excellent chances for a quick win so I
picked the Danish gambit which
exemplifies all of these themes which
you will find in any gambit line okay so
as I was just talking with the audience
we're talking about opening repertoires
and kind of what he plays well one of
the audience members plays and the
Italian game came up and what I told him
was that's a super solid way to handle
open games namely that the answer d5 in
response to e4 on which leads us into
the broad category of open games I all
sharing the common characteristic of and
the objective being a King side attack
an open Center being one of the things
we want to strive for when we play e4
and are met with e5 um and as in all
openings we want to develop rapidly it
was all of these ideas in mind
again not concerned with losing a pawn
or two in order to get our pieces out
fast we answer d4 with we answer a five
would be for black except C no logical
reason not to and whether or not you're
going you intend on declining the gambit
most people most people agree most
players that at the higher levels would
say that taking on d4 is a reasonable
choice white not satisfied with gambling
just one fond says you can have another
my friend black in the spirit of like
and free stuff takes it and for those of
you for the fastidious among us no doubt
black can decline the gambit in this way
white can answer by taking with a bishop
and having a slightly better position on
in as much as he has the space advantage
he's controlling stuff and he has a
piece develops whereas black has none of
that
another response that I often see at the
in the casual play area where I play
this several times a week is night s62
which I will always answer with a
response keynote that will seem familiar
to those of us who play a one night s it
one night f6 and answer to e4 that all
um defense a similar spirit I just go
for the early v e4 e5 push and Glock has
to be very accurate in his response nine
h5 is really a case in point exact a
case in point illustrating why a knight
on the rim is grim or dim as the old
saying goes and Nijs certainly just as
bad as it looks
setting up for the next game as one of
our favorite jams here likes to say so
centralizing the knight and this by the
way was a recommendation of nimzowitsch
one is six Mansoor - uh g3 you have to
centralize the night white says I will
gladly take that strong pawn center
black protects tonight and we're just
playing chess at this point to go any
further down that line is kind of
outside the scope of the Danish gambit
accepted which is what we're looking at
today so after black accepts the pawn on
c3 again white throws caution to the
wind in favor of the principles of rapid
developments he neglects the idea of
material in the idea of recapturing the
pawn on c3 in favor of rapid development
already setting our sights on that frail
and weak f7 square which is the theme in
so many of these p45 opening is an
attack on f7 that is
black says this guy a beginner he just
gave me three pawns in the opening why
cuz hmm I gave you two this third one
was just a means to further my agenda
developing rapidly you not only have one
Bishop on a strong diagonal but we have
to at this point and one thing we'll see
as we look through the rest of the
theory and the oncoming moves that this
is a serious problem the weakness of the
g7 Square has pointed out or accentuated
by the bishop on v2 it makes it really
hard for blacks to develop on this king
side and get ready to castle because he
always has to be concerned was Bishop
take c7 even though in some lines black
certainly has his option which we will
be looking at several points from stages
in this crazy wild opening um but often
and especially in the lines that we're
going to look at tonight it's just not
enough so with that in mind I look into
the future and just know that this is
going to be our main line so to speak
I'm known as the Schleck turret event
pioneered by a very strong player of
yesteryear Carl selector and it's a
really cool idea and that encourages lek
to just accept the gambit all the way
because he can you can play this deep
this great d5 move but we will get into
that after we've looked at some of the
more caught common responses which I did
I definitely see more than a d5 when I'm
playing casual players and I'm playing
you know my crowds of 16 in the 1600 and
hundred crowd so after Bishop takes me
to black and also try and follow opening
principle thing I have all this extra
material I'm going to follow that
steinege principle of nights before
bishops
see 6 is arguably best answered by 9 f3
that can answer this in two ways and I
paused for a moment because it occurred
to me that I didn't look at 5 queenie 7
which is a actually a poor idea some but
it's natural idea in response it you
know instead of putting our knight on c6
we're going to be pinning this or
attacking this undefended e4 pawn as
well as threatening with the move 5:27
that is so 9 f3 queenie 7 natural look
and move
at which point y can just proceed with
completing your development and Castle
kingside black plays d6 not grabbing the
pawn on e4 and just to kind of so-so
question out to you there can you see
why he doesn't he played a c6 instead of
grabbing the pawn and that's fine yeah
oh so one one so already and we'll we
might step back to look at even earlier
examples of this you're going to see
that there's a lot of cool tactical
ideas hidden in here um and if black is
careless he will quickly get himself
into a losing position so again just as
the theme of not moving the bishop on
occurs in a lot of these lines because
the bishop on b2 is always attacking g7
we'll also see many teams in what we see
many cases in which white cannot play in
early e4 e5 or as in this case just
leave this a pawn hanging because if
black were greedy enough to take flight
would answer with the killer rook e1
skewering the Queen against the King
acquiring a winning material advantage
black sees that in this case and just
play d6
to which we answer 93 and black and
respond with Knight f6 Bishop g4 is
another idea but we'll take a step back
after we've finished looking at this
line to look at the rest of that so 9 f6
is best answered by 95
this night on t3 is obligated as
famously said by Erin nimzowitsch to
occupy d5 as quickly as possible
especially in a gambit line but just in
general this is a helpful little helpful
little seemingly obvious saying and it
certainly doesn't always apply in order
to defy the detect or defended by c6 or
something like that then probably don't
want to put your knight there but uh in
many cases we overlook and move like 95
exchanging off one of black strongest
developed strongest develops pieces the
knight on f6 entering some some of our
activity in the in the center more or
less forced or yes to move his queen
costing them yet another precious chambo
you know slowing down this development
giving us the opportunity to open up the
e-file which blacks will reasonably try
and close and white will not allow them
to again with the same theme but being
able to hang a piece on the e-file
because if black is greeting takes it we
skewer and because of the idea because
the rule the King never being able to
leave himself in check this Queen is not
able to move out of the pin so keep that
in mind when you try this at home that
that skewer on the e-file is a common
theme and be fine you can keep be
willing to try this so far based on a
little bit that we've looked at yeah
alright its I seriously I strongly
recommend it in casual and online games
just because one it teaches us the price
of a failing to attack when we have more
developed pieces
despite having it some sort of material
deficiency but to it it just you know
it's a great way to kind of expose
yourself to a lot of forceful attacking
ideas one of them being this Bishop
sacrifice on that set and have you seen
that in any any of your games
yes okay well I'm telling you you play
the Italian on you're going as you as
you get deeper into it you're going to
see that Bishop takes f7 is it's a
pretty common theme position we've
looked at 596 kind of explored some of
White's answers for that after black
responds to Knight f3 with Queen e7 and
now instead if he decides not to you
know block in his dark squared Bishop
with that move but not so good move of
Queen e7 they're on and he continues
listening the Stein and he says okay
nights before bishops nights before
bishops I'm going to put my knight on f6
and why this is hey man I've got all
these themes memorized
you know the bishop takes on g7 is
deductive black star squared bishop ever
moves and any chance you give me I'm
going to play e5 and open up this e-file
with force or at least kick it kick away
any defenders of the center on so e5
will force black on to e4 like it did in
the other line with early night f6 the
really early night f6 and here we get an
example of what I was talking about a
somatic sacrifice which you my friend
I'm envious of you because this was like
one of the things that definitely hooked
me into chess but you learn all these
rules about oh you can win a game if you
just control the center by occupying it
get your stuff off the back row first
and don't lose stuff and this that's
true to a point until we you start
playing other people who study and then
you need to learn more forceful ideas
sacrificial ideas like this Bishop takes
f7 check which just looks crazy right we
just came away coupons and we're going
to give away a bishop
but when black replies by taking it and
we're just going to ignore te 7 right
now because it blocks in the dark
squared bishop and what's even worse at
least black and try and weathered the
storm by taking that bishop and we play
a move that looks kind of like a
beginner move but far from it
the queen is coming out with force and
she is giving us an example of what is
that the foundation of all hosts of the
majority of tactical ideas the double
attack she performs a simple Queen Fork
on this night on e4 and the king on f7
forcing an to move getting back some
material and a pretty strong attacking
position of keeping your mind that this
guy is never going to Castle unless he's
playing a beginner and then we can we
can castle and see if our opponent knows
the rules right after we've gotten the
stuff out but I don't know don't
necessarily recommend that let's we'll
try one small yeah make sure everyone's
paying attention okay
so hopefully that satisfies us as to why
not f6 doesn't work because you can just
kick it away with E 5 and start your
attack
it follows through on that attacks like
taking on f7 with Bishop okay all right
let's take it back just a little bit and
get into black trying to solve this
problem and defy White's attack on the
g7 pawn with this beautifully placed
there should be two and this is
something that I see very often online
and in the casual play area right there
they should be for check to which you
can reply and I often do but we're not
going to look at that too much tonight
maybe some other time with King f1
before for those of us perhaps a little
little hesitant to forfeit our castling
rights there are definitely many other
reasonable responses to this Bishop b4
check one of them being Knight d2 taking
note of the fact that we're not putting
our knight on c3 allowing our bishop to
maintain his threat nine to six can can
you guess what we play here or just read
the notation that you want um yeah I
don't know but anyway yeah what do you
think we play here based on the other
lines that we've looked at it's okay g3
y z3 this Knight to f3 okay and I get
three that's what you all right I got it
got it no no I get I get what you're
saying yeah $9.99 at three I'm not dad
uh protecting the pin piece and getting
rid of castle like you said
but we just gave up two ponds so the
price for that is that we got to be
super aggressive and if we play even one
slightly passive move then we're going
to pay for not for not caring about
having our material and for that reason
we've got to take advantage of this
advanced e4 pawn and kick that night
away so whenever you see Knight f6 in
this line just check-in
you can almost automatically play e5 I
would say almost automatically and yes
there are ideas there are ideas like
queenie 7 here too which we'll just
answer with quick close with Queen e2
renewing the threat of taking this guy
and it can get pretty wild at that point
but I don't want to trail off into too
much craziness I just want to give us a
general idea of some ways that this line
can go and so that being said after 94
is just kicked away we again follow
through with its wild sacrifice idea so
like some of the clues are if the knight
on f6 can we kick it away with E 5 if
your king is not castled yet can we take
on f7 with the bishop because almost
always if he takes we'll have this
similar idea of forking it's dark
squared Bishop all right
you'll run and we'll take it we'll say
hahahah on but in some lines we have to
be aware of the fact that you can say
I'm on to you and your crazy idea of
giving stuff away so you can draw a like
hang out I'm not going to take that
Bishop to which we have a wild response
that is hard to find and separates the
you know the strong attackers from the
not so strong attackers sub and that is
this wild answer to King f8 Bishop a3
putting it on an attack square look at
the direct response to that it's just
taking on four at which point the King
will capture on f7 and can you guess the
theme so we've looked at the e4 e5 being
a theme Bishop takes f7 check being a
big theme in the Danish gambit what's
another theme that I haven't really
pointed out but maybe you'll see it's
this Fork with the Queen against the
bishop and King yes sir and in this case
where she going yeah well said and
you're convinced would you more or less
maybe not yeah I'd be happy to take
white here honestly because I just got
to move my knives and Castle and black
still has two minors to develop his King
is never leaving the center and I think
I could I think I could I could work
with that now I'm making the claim that
we've comprehensively explored all of
the possible answers and plans for black
um up until this point but these are the
general ideas for black and this is one
of the most popular and the strongest
responses to this whole idea of giving
up your D and C pawn set to get the
bishops on those strong diagonals and
develop some sort of King side attack
quickly and that is
the free move d5 at which is at which
point is is strongly recommended for
white to just take the bishop black will
play Knight f6 and he five doesn't just
doesn't work simply because you hang the
bishop on d5 right we're not too
concerned with that
we've got three minors developed and
commissioned in comparison to the the
one on in blacks camp the calculation
will let them know that this is more or
less the best way for him to proceed by
exchanging off is only developed piece
on d5 bringing out his other night
giving us the opportunity to play Queen
b3 okay
taking note that if we're not careful
when we play Knight f3 and then Queen b3
black it as is the cases at almost every
turn which is what makes it a
double-edged opening is worth like a
solid opening he is a chance for some
tactical ideas too and 94 or there
should be four are good examples of that
94 working this pin on the Queen hmm you
know what you're going to see me doing
some Danish Danish gambit stuff on
tactics time so if you liked it
get ready for more if not you've been
warned alright thank you for joining us
see you guys next time
[Music]